let's talk about the polls and whether
we can trust them to pick the next u.s
president their new poll here new poll
there joe biden with a nine point lead
president is behind and behind by allah
most national polls have joe biden with
the lead over donald trump
sound familiar polls showing hillary
clinton ahead
this is unheard of in recent
presidential politics just ask hillary
clinton how that turned out for her this
loss hurts
i donald john trump do solemnly swear
the problem is polls are not
predictors i'll repeat that polls are
not
predictors so if polls can't predict a
winner
why are there so many of them can we
trust them
and while we're talking predictions will
trump win again
[Music]
when it comes to picking the winner of a
presidential race
alan lickman thinks opinion polls are a
waste of time
he says they're snapshots not crystal
balls
forget the polls to get the pundits
don't look at who's up and down
day to day keep your eye on the big
picture
of presidential strength and performance
who's on lickman only the guy who's
predicted every winner since 1984.
that's nine u.s presidents in a row he
predicted ronald reagan's win nearly two
years before the vote
he called barack obama's re-election in
2012 when many people thought the race
was too close to call
and against almost all the polls he
picked donald trump at 2016.
so who is lickman picking for 2020 we'll
get to that in a bit
but first let's talk about the polls
there are national polls state polls and
a whole lot of other polls
and they all do things differently u.s
broadcasters like cnn and fox news do
their surveys over the phone
associated press and the pew research
center recruit people offline but their
surveys are online
pollsters might ask questions like would
you say that your choice of trump
is more vote for trump or more a vote
against biden
it's key to keep them as neutral as
possible we don't want to tilt
people towards one answer or another but
there are many
other factors that can influence the
results things like
who paid for the poll because that could
buy us the poster
how were participants chosen where are
they from and that's where something
called
waiting comes in it's a calculation used
by pollsters to make sure their sample
is representative of an area state or
the whole country
they adjust the sample for things like
education age
and gender if you think that 60 of
voters are going to be women
then you want to make sure that if you
talk to a thousand people that 600 of
those
roughly are women so those are the kinds
of things pollsters try to do to stay as
accurate as possible but in 2016
a lot were off the mark
[Applause]
back then some said clinton's chances of
winning were high
[Applause]
but she didn't win that's because while
clinton got more votes overall
what's called the popular vote she lost
the electoral college which is the
voting system used to decide the
presidency
our best days are still ahead of us
that rarely happens and the pollsters
didn't see it coming
[Music]
when polls do fail they get outside
attention
and those failures are spectacular it's
the same reason why plane crashes are
extremely rare
but when they do happen they need all
their news
so how the polls get it so wrong well
one of the biggest mistakes in 2016
happened with
staples the pew research center says
there were too many cheap and fast polls
and too many college educated people
were interviewed
college graduates for whatever reason
are more likely to take
surveys they had too many college
graduates so they had too many clinton
supporters and not enough donald trump
supporters to be
accurate prior to 2016
education levels didn't really predict a
lot about how people would vote
but in that election it turned out that
they did
on election day two things happened
first there was a higher turnout in
rural counties
and a lower turnout in urban ones that
helped trump
second there were a lot of undecided
voters who chose trump at the last
minute
the only way to capture that is to keep
polling until the bitter end but even
then
there are still voters who only make up
their minds
in the voting booth but some of them
didn't even get that far
research suggests that in 2016 a lot of
people were discouraged from voting
because according to the polls clinton
looked like a shoeing
that might have caused some people to
stay home because they believed the race
was uncompetitive
holsters say they've learned from their
mistakes they better hope so because the
combination of clinton's loss and
trump's win
convinced a lot of people that polls are
just junk
but two years later the polls for the
u.s midterms helped repair some of the
damage
while 2016 was so many ways to miss in
the 2018 midterms
in the united states polls function very
well they
forecast a democratic landslide and that
was exactly
what we got
[Applause]
and now the polls are back with a
vengeance
a new polling on the 2020 presidential
race former vice president joe biden
with a
lead over president trump president
trump behind in two states the poll also
shows biden with a 10-point lead it
would
take a polling failure much much larger
than on the scale we saw on 2016 for
all of those numbers to be wrong but
david also says
a lot can still change and he's not
alone
there's a poll in early september going
to tell you accurately
what's going to happen in wisconsin in
november you know someone that's been in
the field for 20 years i don't think so
that doesn't mean we can't ever trust
polls there are ways you can verify them
and don't just read one poll read many
it's like getting more than one opinion
the accepted wisdom is that polls do a
good job of taking the pulse of public
opinion
are people worried about losing their
jobs do they care about racial
inequality
what about the pandemic and their health
frankly even with their limitations
which can be substantial
polls are still the best tool that
society has to get
information about what's going on with
the entire public
so let's bring back alan lickman and
find out whether he thinks trump will
win again
he's created what he calls the 13 keys
the keys to the white house
if trump loses out on six or more
lichmann says the president is gone
so number one is midterm elections the
republicans in 2018
did badly so that's strike one against
trump
number two is party nomination he didn't
have to fight for it
so score one for trump three is
incumbency
obviously that's a win for trump any
third parties running
nope he gets another key the short-term
economy
well the u.s is in a recession back for
the president
outlook for the long-term economy also
not good
any major policy changes from the
previous administration
there have been plenty another one for
trump key number eight is social unrest
and race relations in the u.s are awful
so trump loses out there too
then there's scandal my favorite key
oh my gosh only the third president in
history
ever to be impeached by the full house
plus all kinds of other scandals
that counts against him trump takes key
number ten
no foreign policy or military failures
but he loses out on number 11
which is foreign policy or military
successes
his initiatives in north korea and the
middle east and
syria have all gone for north yes he
killed general sulaimani but i guarantee
you
95 of the american people couldn't tell
you who he is
today it's not like killing osama bin
laden
the next one asks whether the incumbent
donald trump is inspirational and
charismatic
according to lickman he is a flashy
showman but he only appeals to a narrow
slice of the electorate
and finally is the challenger joe biden
charismatic and inspirational
lichmann isn't convinced joe biden is a
decent
empathetic guy but he's no barack obama
with john f kennedy so will trump remain
in the white house
according to lickman the president has
lost out on seven of the thirteen keys
one more than necessary to say sorry
trump this time
you're not gonna win so he's pretty
confident
but there's a catch lickman says two
things could throw out his
prediction russian hackers and what he
calls voter suppression by the trump
administration
and 2020 is far from an ordinary
election year
the pandemic and the ruined global
economy made sure of that
this race is still a tough one to call
no matter what the polls say
the original interview with alan
lichtman was conducted by our colleagues
at the take which is an al jazeera
podcast
you can listen to their episode about
polls wherever you get your podcasts
i'll see you next week